[Music]
on this tuesday night ontario's premiere
hints at more restrictions
is a tougher crackdown coming and when
when you have
an inferno you have to turn the hoses
there as variants continue to rise
across canada
and pressure piles on to vaccinate more
canadians faster
no quarantines no mandatory cobit tests
no problem this is an important step
forward a new travel bubble between
australia and new zealand
and sos the perilous rescue in rough
waters
off norway
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight in alberta where
premier jason kenney has moved the
entire province
back to phase one of the public health
restrictions and acknowledgment the
restrictions that were in place
are not working case counts including
the variants are on the rise there as
are admissions to
intensive care as of midnight tonight
all indoor
social gatherings are banned except for
worship services retail stores can stay
open but must reduce their capacity to
15 percent
in-person dining is banned though that
doesn't take effect until friday
heather yorick's west is in calgary
heather is this what medical experts in
alberta were hoping for
no donna it's not the sweeping circuit
breaker type locked out that many
doctors had been
calling for when restrictions take full
effect on friday you'll still for
example be able to
hit a patio or go to the mall there are
new restrictions that are coming into
effect as you mentioned
the question is will they be enough
the mayor of edson alberta is angry it
was in my community
and i had no idea kevin zahara says he
learned from media reports monday that
the p-1 variant was spreading in his
community
earlier in the day the province revealed
via twitter that a returning traveler
had spread the virus to three work sites
in the province
global news later confirmed those sites
belong to ptw energy services
and involved sites in drayton valley
hinton and edson
it's unfortunate that that information
isn't being shared with albertans
that it's not forthcoming because i
think albertans are
are smart enough to make really
important decisions if they have the
information available to them
the p1 outbreaks including an unrelated
outbreak at a workplace in calgary means
the more highly transmissible variant
cases
will only continue to rise between 8 and
i thought 800 and a thousand new cases a
day
and uh if it's going to double in a week
as our modeling shows we'll be at 1600
to
2000 cases to be blunt this
wave is here these trends would threaten
the maximum capacity of our health care
system
by next month right when we're reaching
critical mass of vaccination
it's why the alberta government is
putting new restrictions in place but
stopping
short of a full lockdown starting friday
at noon indoor
dining is no longer permitted but
outdoor patios will still be allowed
group fitness classes are canceled but
one-on-one personal training can
continue
these variants are a real enemy of
public health and of lives
and tired though we may be we cannot
stop now we must defeat these variants
daily case counts currently compare with
the situation alberta faced in
mid-november
but in wave two the province didn't
implement full restrictions
until numbers doubled in early december
this time around with variant cases
alberta hospitals are already feeling
the strain
we can't put wild type cova patients
with variant patients together
so that effectively reduces our hospital
capacity in the copenwood's upstairs
and that trickles down to the emergency
department the new restrictions won't
have an immediate impact for the next
several weeks hospitals will see covet
patient numbers rise
but if these measures are successful the
curve will begin to bend
in 10 days to two weeks time
now an important point to remember is
that these variants
are very easily spread and what other
countries have seen
measures that have worked in the past
and previous waves
may not be as effective this time around
so with these measures still allowing
for
some gatherings even though it's outside
it remains to be seen if they will be
uh if they will go far enough donna all
right heather urich's west in calgary
thanks
it is becoming clear how this new phase
of the pandemic driven by those fast
spreading variants is changing the game
in canada
over 15 000 cases of variants of concern
have now been
reported the b-117 strain first
identified in the uk accounts for over
90 percent of them
cases of the p1 variant first detected
in brazil jumped
from about 460 a week ago to over 857
this week
and younger people are getting sick and
ending up in critical care ontario
reported over 3
000 new cases today 63 percent are
variants of concern
and a record number of people there are
now in intensive care
510 up from 387 last week
toronto isn't waiting for the province
to act it is sending students back to
remote learning
so are appeal region and guelph a number
of public health officers and icu
doctors are asking for a strict
stay-at-home order in ontario
premier doug ford isn't ready to do that
yet
this is moving day by day day by hour by
hour we're going to have further
restrictions
moving forward very very quickly if
there is one thing we have learned in
the last year it is that hesitation and
half measures allow the virus
to win eric sorenson reports
if toronto is the country's coveted hot
spot then a scene like this
makes no sense people clustering in
malls
shopping for non-essentials it was
absolutely jam-packed and i
i truly was hoping that you know people
wouldn't be going in there
ontario's premier feeling besieged amid
demands that he do more with vaccines
and lockdowns
suggested further restrictions are
coming for areas like toronto
when you have an inferno going on
somewhere
you have to turn the hoses there in fact
school boards in toronto the largest in
the country
will shut down to in-person teaching
tomorrow and go to online learning
at least two other school boards are
also moving online
it didn't happen fast enough for one
coveted biostatistician
who already took his child out of school
my 12 year old son
is learning from home he was learning
from home last week right now we have
a lockdown that is noticeably weaker
than the january one
and yet we're dealing with a variant
which is a lot more transmissible covid
variants now make up the majority of
cases in ontario
in toronto alone there are more than 160
active covet outbreaks
the largest number in schools where
there are more than 50 outbreaks
another 35 in child care centers and
there are 47 outbreaks
in community and workplace settings
including offices
factories and grocery stores many are
young essential workers who are getting
sick
but won't qualify for vaccines for
several more weeks
i'm definitely seeing people coming from
these workplaces that are essentially
high density
they're essential and you know many of
the people that i'm seeing
are infecting unfortunately household
members in ontario the curves are
troubling
hospitalizations have turned sharply
higher again
and the number of deaths has also been
bending upward once more
the ontario medical association says
what's needed right now is a more
stringent government stay-at-home order
and what that means i know no one wants
to hear it
is that people should only leave their
homes for essential businesses medical
appointments groceries those kinds of
things
medical officers of health in toronto
peel and ottawa have specifically chimed
in for stay-at-home orders
and provincial public health officials
are signaling that new restrictions
could come as early as tomorrow
in the hot zones that are asking for
them eric sorensen global news toronto
quebec has announced more restrictions
for montreal and other regions in the
red zone
beginning on thursday all fitness
centers and gyms which have been a
significant source of the spread will be
closed and starting monday the province
will move high school students to a mix
of in-class
and online learning bc has reported more
than 200 new cases of variance today
though
there's a lag in testing so the real
number is likely higher the province's
top doctor says while there is a lot of
focus on the p1 strain it is the b117
strain that is dominating in bc now
and there are other mutations to keep an
eye on
we also have the p2 which is another
strain that's
is causing a lot of illness in brazil
and it's slightly different from the p1
that we're seeing here
so what we can tell is there's a whole
landscape
of these different viruses and different
variants that we're following
and we see that some of them can really
take off there is growing recognition
the age-based vaccination strategy needs
to be modified to include younger
essential workers
as abigail beeman reports the federal
government is under intense pressure to
get more vaccines into the country
faster it was the prime minister's first
address in a week a week that saw
climbing colvin 19 cases
and an 18 percent increase of people in
icus
covid19 isn't done with us yet
that means we all have to hold tight a
little longer
justin trudeau said he's speaking to
ontario premier doug ford tuesday
and all premiers wednesday if anyone
needs
extra help the federal government will
be there facing criticism over canada's
bleak vaccination rate his health
minister tweeted a thread
showing 10 million vaccines have been
delivered nationally
35 percent sit in freezers one and a
half million of those in ontario
we just got those we literally got them
a few days ago
questioned repeatedly patti haider
refused to say if she felt the rollout
was too slow
stressing she was just trying to provide
clear facts we've heard all along that
it's confusing that numbers are you know
flying out of a variety of different
sources and you can prevent
more deaths and more hospitalizations
and more
infections by focusing
on and prioritizing those people who are
at risk of exposure
as vaccination rates inch up there's
concern essential workers aren't getting
them fast enough
by the end of the week those age 40 to
59 who are
front line workers who are interacting
in person with the public and who cannot
work virtually
will be able to start booking their
appointments bc had a plan to prioritize
essential workers
now forced to retool after the advice
not to give the astrazeneca vaccine to
those
under 55. the biggest problem is still
in ontario
dr zane chagla says the infection rate
is two and a half times higher in some
neighborhoods there
home to more essential workers
uncontrolled community
transmission is leading to
hospitalizations is leading to
scarce icu resources is really leading
to that healthcare apocalypse that we
thought was going to happen
at the very beginning of this pandemic a
year later in round three
the alarm bells keep ringing abigail
beeman global news
ottawa as canada vaccinates tens of
thousands of people each day the u.s is
immunizing americans by the millions
every day
and today president joe biden said every
adult will be eligible for a vaccine by
mid-april jackson prosko reports on
america's accelerated vaccine strategy
in the u.s the newly vaccinated keep
getting younger
in wisconsin every adult is now eligible
eighteen-year-old ella wareham
is thrilled i play sports so i'm really
excited to be able to play against other
teams and
maybe have like concerts come back and
stuff what's happening here will soon
happen across the u.s
as president joe biden directs states to
open up eligibility to all adults
weeks ahead of schedule we've vaccinated
more people than any other nation on
earth
40 of adults have had at least their
first shot
vaccination is happening at a rate five
times faster than the global average
if you were still living in canada would
you have qualified for a vaccine
no definitely not thirty-six-year-old
canadian chris bowman who lives in
denver
was able to take advantage of that ample
supply
like many canadians in the u.s he was
immunized weeks before his parents back
home
part of the reason why i tried so hard
to accelerate my ability to do it is so
that
i could come back and visit family but
there was a sense of guilt
at the same time just like in canada the
us
also faces the threat of a virus
resurgence
cases are spiking in 20 states as the
b-117 variant
first detected in the uk becomes
dominant
it definitely feels like deja vu all
over again you know
but again we know what to do yet some
americans are just as quickly letting
down their guard
from packed stadiums in texas to
california which says it could fully
reopen by mid-june
we're in a race between vaccines and
variants
and eventually the vaccines are going to
win but in the interim period we still
have a lot of opportunity for spread
the pandemic may not be over but in the
virus-ravaged u.s
the end is finally in sight jackson
prosko global news
washington amia culpa at the
investigation into misconduct within
canada's military coming up why the
country's former top
civil servant is saying sorry
more developments in the investigation
into former chief of the defense staff
general jonathan vance today the
country's
former top civil servant testifying at
the national defense committee
apologized for the way allegations
against vance
were handled our ottawa bureau chief
mercedes stevenson is with me mercedes
what did michael wernick say well donna
it's not often that there are apologies
from senior government officials and in
this particular incident
the prime minister and the defense
minister have not apologized or really
said that a lot more should have been
done in the wake of the allegations
against former chief of the defense
staff general jonathan vance
but today canada's former top bureaucrat
michael wernick
did do just that he acknowledged that
more could have been done for the
victims
and that misconduct in the forces might
have been stopped earlier
if more action was taken instead
politicians and bureaucrats he said
became sidetracked with other issues
including a coming election
i think collectively the system failed
and it let down the complainant and it
let down the women and men of the armed
forces and i deeply regret that
in fact i would like to apologize to
them if my my decisions or or decisions
not to do something prolong this
i sincerely apologize to the men and
women of the forces for that
wernicke said that he and minister sajin
did speak directly against
about john vance's performance pardon me
and whether or not he should stay on
longer and that there were other
concerns about things happening in the
military including the high rate of
turnover with senior officers
and vance's desire to stay on apparently
until up to 2022
but none of this seems to have come
along with more discussion
about those allegations against john
vance mercedes we also heard from the
defense minister about whether further
investigation by him would have amounted
to political interference
where does that issue stand while sajin
continued to defend his response of not
accepting that envelope with evidence
but today michael wernick had a
different opinion listen to this
he had the alternative of accepting the
envelope and immediately giving it to
somebody to send over to
us he could have acted as the courier
and said okay i'll take it from you but
i'm sending it to pco
and i do think that mr wahlburn could
have found some redacted version of the
information to give to us that might
have
might have hypothetically given us more
to go on
wernick says if they had had that
envelope perhaps they might have been
able to do more
but in a forward look donna he says the
military culture must change
all right mercedes stevenson in ottawa
thank you a daring rescue at sea
still ahead why the crew of this vessel
had to abandon ship
a risky rescue in the north sea on
monday a dutch cargo ship lost power and
began
to list fearing it would capsize some of
the crew abandoned ship they jumped into
waves that were up to 15 meters high
all 12 were safely picked up by a
norwegian rescue team
the ship is still adrift about 74
kilometers off norway's coast it's at
risk of sinking and causing an oil spill
crews are now mobilizing to try to
figure out a way to stabilize it
iran says it has indicted 10 officials
in connection with the downing of that
ukrainian passenger jet
176 people on board were killed
including dozens of people
bound for canada none of the officials
has been named and it's unclear their
specific connection to the strike
ukrainian
airlines flight 752 was struck by two
missiles
minutes after taking off from tehran in
january 2020.
the iranian government blamed human
error in its final report released last
month saying the plane was
misidentified as a hostile target the
canadian government condemned those
findings and prime minister justin
trudeau vows to keep pressure on iran to
cooperate with a full investigation
the lack of a full and total
investigation means that canada along
with
our fellow countries in the
international contact group
will continue to put pressure on iran
to deliver true accountability and
justice
compensation for the families
85 canadian citizens and permanent
residents were killed
53 other people were also headed to this
country
jailed russian opposition leader alexei
navalny has been moved to a sick ward
and has been tested for covid19
because of his declining health navalny
says he is suffering from a bad cough
and high fever
and claims there has been a tuberculosis
outbreak among his cellmates
navalny's personal doctor who was turned
away from seeing him today says the care
he has been receiving poses
a lethal risk to his health she and
nearly a dozen other supporters were
arrested today
at a demonstration outside his prison
camp navalny who is serving a two and a
half year sentence is nearly a week into
a hunger strike demanding access to
proper care for acute back and leg pain
prison officials say his condition is
satisfactory and they claim he's getting
all the help he needs the pandemic has
brought economic uncertainty to many
but it's been a great year for
billionaires forbes
35th annual list of the world's richest
people shows
there are now 2755 billionaires that is
the highest count on record
493 are newcomers that means a new
billionaire was minted roughly every
17 hours amazon's jeff bezos topped the
list for
a fourth year running altogether this
year's list is worth
8 trillion dollars more than the 2020
list
hard to get your head around that
quarantine
free travel next the bubble plan for two
countries with covid zero strategies
what's become clear in the last year is
that countries which closed themselves
off and adopted a zero coveted strategy
are far ahead of the rest of the world
new zealand and australia have kept
illnesses and deaths to a minimum
and now they're showing what's possible
when you eliminate cases of covid19
not just flatten the curve redmond
shannon explains
at the start of the pandemic new zealand
locked down
fast and hard the result a country
operating
almost as normal with only four covet
deaths
since may and now prime minister jacinda
ardern has announced a new step
towards normalcy i can confirm that
quarantine free travel between new
zealand
and australia will commence in just
under two weeks time
for the past six months australians have
been welcoming travelers from new
zealand without quarantine
now with community transmission almost
eliminated in australia too
the favor can be returned we have
ensured that both our countries have
been despite
dealing with the virus have not suffered
the same
types of virus impacts that we've seen
in so many other
countries around the world that's
because the colonial cousins both
adopted
a zero covid strategy building on
already strong border controls with
quarantine hotels from early on
and short sharp circuit breaker
lockdowns when a new case emerged
the effort has paid off i know families
friends and significant parts of our
economy will welcome it
as i know i certainly do
many australians are eager to jump on a
plane
across the tasman sea absolutely out of
this world
my three grandchildren are living in new
zealand it's a bit of a rainbow
at the end of this long long process
it's being
the bubble begins on april 19th the same
day as canada's atlantic travel bubble
resumes
ardern has stressed that any
resurgencing cases
could see the arrangement suspended
redmond shannon global news
london and that is global national for
this tuesday i'm donna friesen
tonight's your canada is winnie the dog
admiring the sunset in calgary we are
told winnie is a big fan of global
national
and we are choosing to take that as a
compliment rather than thinking we're
going to the dogs so woof woof to you
winnie thanks for watching
and i hope to see you here again
tomorrow take care of yourself
[Music]
bye-bye
[Applause]
[Music]
you